Salut! je viens juste de rentrer de tournée de Narbonne
Et la dernière vidéo que j'ai mise en ligne, qui doit être juste ici
est sortie il y a précisément trois heures.
Et durant toute la durée du train j'ai répondu aux commentaires
Et franchement, ça méritait de faire une vidéo !
Il y a eu trois types de réponses :
Générique
[Catégorie 1] Il y a eu en masse tout ceux qui sont nés en 2002
Qui me sont tombés dessus en mode "mais ouais mais ça ne marche pas sur 2002"
Ce qui est vrai, c'est un oubli de ma part, je m'excuse
J'ai pas pensé à cette possibilité là
C'étais d'ailleurs le même cas pour 1991
Ils ont été moins ... violents !
Et moi vite pour pallier à ça j'ai mis un commentaire que j'ai épinglé
qui n'a servi à rien !
A rien ! Mais ça ne sert à rien en fait d'épingler un message puisqu'en fait personne le lit.
Par contre j'ai appris un truc !
Si je veux qu'il y ait masse commentaire il suffit de faire volontairement une petite erreur
et ça reproduirait le même truc
Donc là en fait j'ai décroché, d'habitude je lis toujours tous les commentaires
j'essaye de répondre un petit peu et tout
Et là, bah en fait c'est trop !
C'est du spam !
[Catégorie 2] La deuxième réaction qui était un petit peu plus étonnante
C'était de trouver le concept débile.
Alors je peux le comprendre qu'il ne plaise pas le concept, attention!
Mais "Débile" ?!
Il y en avait beaucoup qui me reprochait que ce n'était pas vraiment du mentalisme
qu'en fait il y avait une explication rationnelle,
qu'il y avait un peu de maths cachés derrière,
du coup ça va pas, c'est nul et tout.
Ca c'est marrant, parce que dans la vidéo je dis clairement au début " je vais faire un truc qui va vous bluffer, enfin peut-être"
[Extrait de la vidéo d'hier] : l'idée c'est de vous surprendre, peut-être, c'est parti
et en fin de vidéo je vous dis " j'espère que cette expérience de logique"
puisque c'est une expérience logique, il y a un fondement mathématique derrière, on est bien d'accord avec ça
[Extrait de la vidéo d'hier] D'autres vidéos comme ça qui sont des vidéos un petit peu de divertissement logique
Alors je me suis dit je vais faire cette vidéo
j'ai pas beaucoup dormi, je sors du train, mais j'ai allumé direct la caméra
En fait cette vidéo ça fait quand même pas mal de temps que je la réfléchi
que je l'écrit, que je l'ai tournée du coup
Et j'ai mis 4 jours à la monter, c'est le maximum que j'ai mis pour monter une vidéo
J'ai essayé de faire beaucoup d'effets à l'intérieur, même un peu de tracking sur mes mains et tout ...
Et le but de la vidéo - et de cette série que je voulais lancer - c'était du divertissement
Un samedi matin, peut-être une fois par mois faire un truc un peu rigolo, un peu surprenant, mais qui peut s'expliquer
Juste le principe d'un truc "rigolo"
Et beh tu me crois, tu ne me crois pas, ça m'a bien détendu !
Donc je pense que je n'en re-ferai plus - voilà, c'était la petite annonce du jour
On va continuer sur les astuces, on va continuer "moi quand je bluffe des gens", du boost brain
Mais j'en re-ferai pas des comme ça écoute, peut-être que je me suis planté et c'est pas grave
En tout cas merci à la 3ème catégorie - c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont bien aimé la vidéo, c'est cool
Ca me faisait chaud au cœur
Même si j'ai moins vu vos messages noyés dans tous les commentaires de " c'est nul, ça marche pas"
Ah oui parce que il y a aussi une 4ème petite catégorie
Ça c'est l'ultime ! [Catégorie bonus]
C'est tout ceux qui font "c'est de la merde, ça ne marche pas"
Parce que eux se sont trompés dans leurs calculs de départ
Il y avait un calcul, il y avait une soustraction à faire c'était le seul truc
et quand tu te plantes dans la soustraction - ça ça arrive -
Je veux dire, ça m'arrive aussi
Mais ne viens pas m'insulter moi parce que tu t'es trompé(e) toi.
C'était censé être un petit format hors-série que je voulais lancer
Là j'en avait une autre sur un concept de 360°
Une autre sur un concept d'une espèce de verre
Bon j'oublie, vu le temps que ça me prend par rapport à ça j'oublie
Et je note précieusement qu'une petite vidéo, juste pour vous amuser en début de weekend
C'est pas le top!
Ne voyez aucune agressivité dans cette vidéo
Vous devez même voir que je suis plutôt amusé par ce qui vient de se passer
C'était révélateur de plein de trucs !
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner ou à vous ré-abonner si vous vous étiez désabonnés à cause de la vidéo de samedi ! Ciao !
Musique de générique de fin